the corona virus outbreak continues to
advance around the world the number of
cases in China and South Korea keeps
rising but at a slowing rate however the
outbreak in Iran Italy Switzerland and
now France and Germany is growing in
Italy alone we've seen 1492 more cases
overnight and a hundred and two more
deaths here in the UK as of this morning
there were 319 confirmed cases very
sadly this now includes four confirmed
deaths I entirely understand why people
are worried and concerned and we send
our condolences to the families the UK
response is guided by our four point
action plan we continue to work to
contain the virus but we're also taking
action to delay its impact to fund
research and to mitigate its
consequences throughout our approach is
guided by the science that is the
bedrock on which we base all our
decisions our plan sets out what we're
prepared to do and we'll make the right
choices of which action to pursue the
right moment the scientific advice is
clear acting too early creates its own
risks so we will do what is right to
keep people safe guided by the science
will act at the right time and will be
clear and open about our actions and the
reasons for them madam Deputy Speaker
these are the principles that underpin
the very best response to an academic
like this turning to research I can
report to the house that we've made
available a further 46 million to find a
vaccine and develop more rapid
diagnostic tests we'll continue to
support the international effort here at
home the NHS is well prepared with
record numbers of staff record nurses
and record doctors I want to thank all
those involved for their work so far the
number of calls to NHS one-one-one has
increased and we've now added
an extra 700 people to support that
effort one more one online is now
dealing with more inquiries than the
voice calls today public health England
has tested nearly 25,000 people and the
time taken to test is being reduced as
we're bringing in a new system for
faster results
but of course responding to coronavirus
will take a national effort and everyone
must play their part of course that
means government it also means everyone
washing their hands more often and
following public health advice but there
is much more that we can all do both
through volunteering and through support
for those who are the most vulnerable
will shortly bring forward legislative
options to help people and services to
tackle this outbreak the bill will be
temporary and proportionate with
measures that last only as long as
necessary in line with clinical advice
and I can also report that over the
weekend we initiated action to help 120
passengers on the Grand Princess cruise
ship off the coast of California to
assist them in coming home madam Deputy
Speaker we will stop at nothing to get
this response right and I commend this
statement to the house